you've probably asked the question
before iphone
or android apple maps or google maps
safari or chrome on the surface
apple and google represent the ultimate
tech rivalry
but behind the scenes executives have
maintained a multi-billion dollar
partnership
that benefits them both massively i
would describe apple and google as the
classic example of frenemies
on one hand they're fierce rivals on the
other hand
they benefit greatly from figuring out
ways to work together
google pays apple an estimated 8 to 12
billion dollars a year
or a third of alphabet's annual profits
to make sure it's the
default search engine on more than a
billion apple devices
that deal has helped google dominate the
search market
in recent years it's accounted for 90 to
95
of search engine queries in the us the
deal between the two tech giants is so
powerful
that it's at the center of one of the
biggest us government lawsuits against a
public company
since the 90s so how did two of silicon
valley's biggest
rivals come to form one of tech's most
valuable partnerships
to understand apple and google's frenemy
relationship
you have to go back to the beginning
in the early days they were quite close
at the time
the ceo of google was on apple's board
it was
part of the silicon valley club if you
will
in 2005 the two companies laid the
groundwork for what would become one of
the industry's biggest deals
google struck a deal with apple to
become the default search engine for
safari on mac
computers as apple evolved so did the
relationship
in 2007 when the iphone came out google
was then the
default search for the iphone safari
browser and it's really just grown and
grown
from that point so steve
you know i've had the privilege of
joining joining the board and there's a
lot of relationships between the boards
and i thought you know if we just sort
of merged the companies we could call
them apple goo
as it became clear that google was going
to be more than just a search engine and
that it wanted to grow
and that apple was going to be a rival
that
that became an issue in 2008
google directly challenged apple's
business with the launch of its android
operating system
the next year google ceo eric schmidt
resigned from apple's board since then
both companies have expanded into each
other's businesses
with google launching android phones and
apple launching services like the app
store
and siri which was originally powered by
microsoft's bing
not google search wikipedia for neil
armstrong
[Music]
searching for neil armstrong it wasn't
until 2017
that apple switched from bing to google
for its search results on siri
and spotlight the max search function
that renewed deal between apple and
google came at a good time for both
companies
google was facing competition from
facebook's fast growing mobile ad
revenue
and its new deal with apple put its
search results
and ads on more than a billion apple
devices
now up to half of google searches come
from apple devices
when you open up your iphone and go to
safari and
write something that you want to search
for boom you're going to google
that's a lot of value for apple the deal
has benefited its business
two-fold first it got more consistent
search results across safari
siri and spotlight but perhaps more
importantly
the money it gets from google's ad
revenue makes up 15 to 20
of apple's annual profits that's helped
fund apple's ambitions to grow its
services unit
which has driven growth for the company
over the past few years
apple is like a store it's selling its
shelf space the primo
shelf space and so when you go into a
store and you see those
candy bars right there at the register
that's the place to be if you're selling
candy bars
and so for google they're in that
default spot
now all of that money and search traffic
could be at risk
because of this lawsuit in october the
u.s department of justice sued google
over antitrust concerns the government
is alleging that google is a monopoly
gatekeeper for the internet
and it says that harms customers
advertisers
and competing tech companies one way the
justice department says google maintains
its dominance
is through exclusive business deals like
through its partnership with apple
according to the lawsuit some people at
google called the prospect of losing its
default status on apple devices
code red google representatives said
they weren't aware of the code red
language used in the lawsuit
and neither apple or google have
officially disclosed the exact value of
the deal
or commented on the justice department's
8 to 12 billion
projection in a recent interview the
journal's personal tech columnist joanna
stern
asked google's former ceo about the deal
there was ultimately a deal that i did
not personally negotiate but it was a
lucrative deal for apple
uh but important to say that with
respect to google
and respect to use of google search on
apple phones it is extremely easy to
switch to another
provider google has denied the justice
department's allegations
and said it plans to challenge the
lawsuit its chief legal officer
said the lawsuit wouldn't help consumers
and that its relationship with apple is
customary
apple hasn't officially commented on the
lawsuit
so what happens if the justice
department is successful in its case
this could drag out for many years this
is an interesting situation
in some ways if the doj is successful
the
one of the companies that might be
harmed the most here is apple given the
fact that they perhaps have 15 or
20 percent of their profit coming from
this relationship of course
there are other search engines out there
like bing duckduckgo
baidu and yandex but none of them even
come
close to google's dominance some
financial analysts say that if anyone
can give google a run for its money
it's apple and the antitrust lawsuit
might just be the push apple needs to
divorce itself from google
we don't know exactly where apple is
going
with its future plans here some have
speculated
that potentially this would be a good
reason for apple to
develop its own search engine others
have said
potentially they might buy a search
engine to beef up that capability
one of the things we know about apple
over the years is that it likes to own
its core competencies so it can control
those worlds
and so you know that's always kind of
hanging in the background
apple hasn't responded to requests for
comment on plans to create or
purchase its own search engine still
a breakup of this multi-billion dollar
partnership between apple and google
could deal a financial blow to two of
the world's biggest companies
and however this relationship plays out
in the future has the potential to shape
the way billions of people
use the internet as we see
congress and regulators debate the power
of tech
this lawsuit is just yet another example
of kind of that
public debate about their role
in our future in our society
you